Being from Germany,
Thanksgiving is not something that I'm super familiar with.
Over the years I've gotten a little bit more familiar with it,
and since we won't be home for the holidays this year,
I decided to cook us a little Thanksgiving spread ahead of time.
Started by making a roasted garlic,
lemon zest, compound butter,
and also prepping some sweet potatoes for a sweet potato rolls.
Let my yeast bloom and some warm milk,
then added some honey, some eggs,
our sweet potatoes, butter and flour.
I let that go until it came together,
and then I called lucky to knead the dough
for about five to eight minutes.
Once it was smooth,
I let it rise for two hours while I got started on our stuffing.
Since I didn't have stale bread,
I roasted my bread until it was toasted.
While that was cooling, I chopped up some carrot,
celery, onion.
I like adding some sausage to my stuffing,
so today it was a chorizo pork sausage.
I combined my torn up bread with with my mixture,
put that in a baking dish,
topped it with some parsley,
and baked until it was golden brown.
And then it was time to get started on our bird.
Lucky does not like Turkey,
so I usually opt for a roast chicken.
Today it was fennel and citrus roast chicken.
Put my compound butter under the skin,
on top, stuff it with celery,
and bake it at 3:50 for about Three hours.
I also prepped some maple glazed carrots
and cranberry salsa to go on top of those.
This point, my dough was ready to get worked with,
so I punched the air out and formed it into little rolls,
put those in my baking dish,
and let them poop for about 45 more minutes.
In the meantime, started on my mashed potatoes.
I boiled my potatoes, rice them,
combine them with some heavy cream and butter,
and also some roasted garlic.
My favorite thing to make is this miso green bean side dish.
Forgot my rolls were in the oven,
so they got a little darker than I wanted to,
but they were still delicious.
I let my chicken rest, plated all of my side dishes,
also my gravy, and this was absolutely divine.